what's stronger a witch king or a white
wizard and what happened to all those
magic rings anyway keep watching to find
out everything you didn't know you
wanted to know about the mythology of
lord of the rings
right from the get-go elves and dwarves
clearly have some serious beef indeed
these two ancient middle-earth races are
at odds at practically every step in the
hobbit the dwarves are less than
friendly with the elves of rivendell and
they're later straight up imprisoned by
the elves of mirkwood in the lord of the
rings gimli and legolas begin their
friendship at odds the elven princeling
hates the idea of going into moria and
the dwarf is nearly refused admission
into lothlorien ishka queen
[Music]
the animosity between elf and dwarf is a
theme that stretches far back through
their ancient histories which are told
in the silmarillion this book reveals
that the root of the conflict can be
found in each race's creation middle
earth's dwarves were brought into being
by an angelic creature named owlet who
made them in an act of disobedience as
he waited for the creator il uvatar to
bring the elves into the world allez
became impatient so he made the dwarves
instead eluvitar caught owlette
red-handed but the creator chose to give
these new creations their own individual
wills however he also told alay that
often strife shall arise between thine
and mine the children of my adoption and
the children of my choice this
immediately set the tone for the dwarves
to live fiercely independent lives
separate from the other children of
iluvatar and often in direct competition
with them
the age of men
is over
the time
of the orc
has come
in the two towers tree beard tells mary
and pippin that orcs were made in
mockery of elves during middle earth's
great darkness however tolkien never
totally clarified the exact origin of
the orcs nevertheless in the
silmarillion he does offer one very
compelling account for their creation
tolkien explains that when the elves
first came into existence they were
alone in middle earth living in
childlike innocence in a world of
perpetual starlight eventually they
became afraid of wandering off alone as
an unknown being they called the hunter
had begun to carry them off this hunter
turned out to be the dark lord morgoth
and his servants the fate of his
captives was uncertain but it was
surmised by the wise of middle earth
that by slow arts of cruelty the elves
were corrupted and enslaved and thus did
morgoth breathe the hideous race of the
orcs in envy and mockery of the elves of
whom they were afterwards the bitterest
foes while the orcs likely began as
corrupted elves before long they had
taken on their own attributes but even
as the enemies of middle earth's free
peoples tolkien points out that deep in
their dark hearts the orcs still loathe
the maker of their misery the creation
of the orcs has been referred to by
tolkien as morgoth's vilest deed and the
one that caused the most defense to
iluvatar
so you know where orcs come from but
what's the deal with urakai how are
sauromon's oversized servants different
from their orcish counterparts after all
they appear to have orcish features but
they're uncommonly tall and muscular
much like the history of the orcs
themselves tolkien was never crystal
clear about the answer to this question
but he does offer a few hints in the two
towers
whom do you serve
saruman
first of all it seems fair to suggest
that the urakai are an offshoot breed of
orcs in other words they are at least
partially part of the orc family tree in
the two towers treebeard states that
saruman has been doing something to the
orcs something dangerous for these
eisengarders are more like wicked men he
adds that normal orcs cannot stand the
sun but the urukai can even if they
don't exactly love it from there
treebeard wonders are they men he has
ruined or has he blended the races of
orcs and men during the battle of helm's
deep the urukai are also referred to as
half orcs and goblin men while the truth
remains hazy it appears that the white
wizard may have crossbred orcs and men
to create his own breed of soldier
the exact purpose of the one ring is
kept vague in both the lord of the rings
films and the books however if you
cobble together enough of the facts it
is possible to paint a better picture of
the true power of everyone's favorite
trinket in the silmarillion sauron
forges the one ring part way through the
second age when this happens he binds
the other rings of power to it in order
to gain an intimate level of domination
over their owners in essence sauron is
able to use the ring to see what the
other ring bearers are thinking and even
control their thoughts
[Music]
however sauron's initial plan backfires
and the elves proved strong enough to
resist his will nevertheless the one
ring retains its control over most of
the other rings of power existing
primarily as an instrument of evil
domination while this is the primary
purpose of the one ring it also provides
the wearer with several other advantages
obviously it can make an individual
disappear when they want to it can also
slow the aging process or even halt it
indefinitely on top of that when sam
briefly puts on the ring after fleeing
shelob's lair he is able to understand
the conversation of nearby orcs in the
text tolkien suggests that the ring may
have given him the ability to translate
the orcs language notably the same thing
happened to bilbo when he encountered
the spiders of mirkwood in the hobbit
the timelines of peter jackson's movies
and tolkien's books come to cross
purposes fairly early in the telling
arguably this throws off the timing of
the whole story leading to the question
how long does frodo have the one ring
before he becomes mordor bound the
correct answer in the books is 17 years
frodo receives his inheritance from
bilbo on his 33rd birthday in the movie
version of that long expected party mary
and pippen are practically full
full-grown when they get into trouble
with gandalf this gives the
understandable impression that very
little time passes between that event
and the moment at which the four hobbits
begin their quest the truth is though in
the book version of the fellowship of
the ring a whopping 17 years elapse
between frodo getting the ring and frodo
leaving the shire and that's 17 years
exactly in fact he receives the ring on
his 33rd birthday and departs the shire
on his 50th in the novel this goes a
long way in explaining why he's so
attached to the ring right from the
get-go
while john noble does a fantastic job
portraying denathore on the silver
screen the cinematic version of the
steward of gondor doesn't exactly do
justice to the book he's arrogant to a
fault blinded by pride and literally
tells his men to leave minas tirith when
it comes under attack
[Music]
worst of all he orders faramir to attack
oscar leath when there's no question
that he's going to be moaned down by an
army of orcish archers all of this
behavior is so over the top that it begs
the question what the heck is going on
well if you turn to the original text
the answer becomes clear namely the fact
that his poor judgment is far more
nuanced in the books denethor isn't a
mad tyrant openly trying to kill his son
on the contrary while he does make his
disappointment in vermeer clear he
doesn't send his son on a suicide
mission instead when faramir retreats to
ministerith to report on the situation
in ascalia denathor simply asks him to
return and bolster the defenses more
generally the steward's hopeless despair
comes about because he has been battling
sauron's will through one of the
palantir all in all the book version of
denathor is a deeply flawed man but he's
also strong and noble and gives
everything he has to the defense of
gondor
hobbits are a curious people they share
similarities with men dwarves and even
elves at times which often leads to the
question of whether or not tolkien meant
for them to be related to any of these
other races well they are related to one
of them men to be precise at least
they're most likely related to them
again tolkien left this one a little
open-ended in the prologue to the
fellowship of the ring he spends a
decent amount of time breaking down the
history ancestry and culture of the
little people in the middle of the
breakdown he straight up states that it
is plain indeed that in spite of later
estrangement hobbits are relatives of
men while this is presented as an
obvious fact he also points out that the
beginning of hobbits lies far back in
the elder days that are now lost and
forgotten he also points out that the
true relationship between hobbits and
men quote can no longer be discovered so
while tolkien refuses to make any
specific connection between the two he
all but declares that hobbits are a
miniature version of the big people
a number of rings of power appear
throughout the lord of the rings and the
hobbit movies nine rings are wielded by
mortal men doomed to die the three elven
rings are used to keep all that is good
and holy intact and of course there's
the one ring itself which serves as the
focal point to the entire story but what
about the seven dwarven rings these are
shown briefly at the beginning of the
fellowship of the ring and they're
mentioned every time the ring poem is
recited but that's about it so what
happened to them well gandalf provides a
bit of clarity on the subject in the
fellowship of the ring when he hastily
brings frodo up to date on the long lore
of the rings of power he briefly
mentions that seven the dwarf kings
possessed but three sauron has recovered
and the others the dragons have consumed
this is partially confirmed later on
when gandalf suggests that dragonfire
could destroy the lesser rings then at
the council of elrond gloyne informs the
group that a messenger from mordor asked
for the dwarf's help in hunting for the
one ring the price offered in exchange
three rings that the dwarf sires
possessed of old
one of the biggest issues that many fans
have with the lord of the rings movies
comes from a scene in the extended
edition of the return of the king in
which the witch king confronts gandalf
on the walls of minas tirith
faced with the awesome power of the
white wizard sauron's captain
nonetheless overpowers him destroying
his staff and sending him hurtling to
the ground so is gandalf the white
really weaker than one of the nazgul
while this is a generally speculative
question it's probably safe to assume
that peter jackson and company
overstepped a little here that's not a
knock against the witch king of course
angmar's erstwhile ruler is thousands of
years old wields a ring of power and is
backed by the strongest being in middle
earth but we're not comparing him to a
run-of-the-mill mortal here or even an
elven lord this is gandalf he's an
angelic being placed inside a mortal
body one who is older than time itself
and happens to be secretly wielding one
of the elven rings of power no matter
which way you slice it the witch king
would never be able to defeat gandalf
this easily in the books the two
characters do briefly face each other
but before they can come to blows the
rohirrim arrive and the witch king
retreats still it's probably safe to say
that the witch king wouldn't have won
that fight
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you